my idea is for the 2024 Labour Party manifesto
I've got 10 policies here
and I've tried to get a balance
between actually being able to get elected
and making some genuine change
I'm very interested to know your opinions
on all of these policies
especially if you're someone who's more
traditionally in the centre
and doesn't really have a
loyalty to either party
would you vote for this manifesto in 2024
and if not policy 1
raise the minimum wage to 15 an hour
we need a genuine living wage in this country
and there is massive support for both labour
and conservative voters
to raise the minimum wage to 15 an hour
it's a policy that would have a massive impact
on so many people's lives
and when it's that popular with the public
it's a no brainer
to put in a manifesto
policy number
raise the current top tax bracket
which is 150 000 pounds plus a year to 47
and then create a new top tax bracket
of 300 000 pounds a year plus
and tax that at 49
a massive majority of people in the uk think
taxes on the ridge are too low
but this policy also isn't too extreme
that it would scare away people
policy No.3
close tax loopholes
this is a fairly self explanatory one
just gotta do your best
to make sure people aren't avoiding tax
policy number
raise the inheritance tax threshold from
325 000 to 400 000
inheritance
is currently taxed out 40 %
on anything over 325 000
with inflation
and housing prices going up so much
it makes sense to raise this
so the average family is able to
pass on a family home to their children
and it can also help deflect the tory line
of attack
that labor is the party of raising taxes
policy number
bring a legislation meaning
the board of directors of any company
employing over 2 000 people
must have a board
with over 50 of its members
elected by the workers
this is a policy that has been in Germany
since 1976
and in several other european countries
has worked very well
I wish the Labour Party
would focus on democracy
and the workplace
a bit more
because I think it's a concept
that would be very popular
if you started talking about it
policy No.6
nationalize rail and energy
rail is almost nationalized already
and has massive public support
to bring it into public hands
and the cost of living crisis
has made the argument
for nationalizing energy for us
and again
there's massive public support
for bringing energy into public hands
as much as
I would like to nationalize
more than that
we have to be smart
with what we put in a manifesto
and nationalizing
things like broadband or water
and not as popular with public
policy No.7
repeal the rwanda policy
this is a pretty unpopular policy
that goes against human rights
and is a massive waste of money
so it should be repealed
and replaced with safe passage No.8
double investment into
local industry and agriculture
domestic farming and manufacturing
has been dying for a very long time
in this country
and I think it's
about time we brought at least some of it back
not only would this create jobs
but it would also be good for the environment
because we wouldn't be importing so much
stuff in from abroad
policy number 9
reversing nhs
primatization
profiteering
has no business in the industry
of healthcare
and public opinion
polls show that
most people are not a fan of privatization
in the nhs
and number 10
the final policy
a wage cap in the public sector
this policy
would cap the top salary in a public sector
at 15 times more
than the lowest
salary in a public sector
so a manager in the nhs
would not be allowed to get paid
over 15 times more than the lowest earner
in the nhs
which policies you
agree with
disagree with
would you vote for this manifesto in 2024
and do you think labor
could win an election
with policies like this